come on Jerry we're gonna watch the
trailer Jerry
sit good boy lil ladies and gentlemen my
name is Ryan Wright and my name is Jerry
and I'm Kath DOS and tonight we're gonna
be watching the trailer or as above so
below I am Patrick Bateman that movie as
above so below has a very cool poster I
saw last night at the cinema a lot of
people are saying I should check this
trailer out I really want to check this
one out because all you guys are saying
it as above so below the ups and downs
of life it's a dramedy that sounds
actually really dark to me like well
well take it out me because I saw it
with the poster first but okay but first
off it's been approved for all audiences
oh good nice new well I'm glad we're not
in violation of anything mm-hmm
my name is scarlet Marlowe and I'm a
student in urban archeology three
hundred and seventy feet beneath this
point is a hidden chamber that might
contain a critical missing piece of our
history how are we supposed to get down
categories
there are 200 miles of tunnels right
underneath our feet holding the remains
of six million corpses
well is the Empire trip
yeah he's a human bones go through here
is dead I think I'm stuck what was that
what the [ __ ] and then we can't go back
she's kidding tell me we didn't discuss
after since I said no we see this upside
down what happened to the entrance wait
here
oh how is this when I was a kid we had a
piano that looked exactly like this I
used to play home time the a4q messed up
what did I want what the mud business
was paralyzed and you read that
according to mythology that's
inscription over the gates of hell and
they should be made to crawl on their
bellies and stick
my god somebody there
Oh
do what it's terrible that looks awesome
that looks beyond scary for sure yeah I
would see that yeah we should watch that
together cats you know if I like you
have to me to comfort you I want you to
reach at the bottom of the popcorn
bucket you know whatever you know you
cut a hole in the bottom of the popcorn
bucket so the popper I'm gonna go break
when you go under the hole he does that
that doesn't make any sense why would
you do that not efficient oh my god this
is supposed to go through the hole and
then when you reach for it supposed to
okay nevermind you get a salty popcorn
you know John talking to our first
grader yeah wish but if you got like
butter then my dick would taste way more
better yeah that movie does look [ __ ]
terrifying as [ __ ] like [ __ ] is pretty
scarier is enough as this I hope it goes
batshit cuz it looks like it's gonna go
bad yeah dude
and I love the concept of like your past
literally haunting you the
claustrophobic setting to the catacombs
not scary enough as it is there's a lot
of scary [ __ ] happening in this [ __ ]
movie anything that involves like the
descent worth like we're climbing
through a rock chute that's only big
enough to kind of fit my body always
freaks me that the [ __ ] our yeah once
you realize just how tight the space is
then it's kind of like oh yeah I kinda
like what I just need she said every
space gets tight and it's kind of like
nope doesn't make sense you guys are
right thought I have one thought I have
one I am failing tonight but it also
looks like a really cool version of Hell
to like like a cool take on Hell
mythology it's a scary ascent and you
say well hello looks pretty cool this
one I'm saying their idea of hell seems
neat it's not just like Oh fire pit
floatiness is like oh every one of these
characters it looks like it's gonna have
to face their own personal version of
Hell so um yeah I guess that's uh that's
what we're gonna say and if you're new
to the channel
am I the only one we got freaked out by
that subscribe button guys I just
informed our viewers that if they're new
to the channel they should subscribe so
what comes after that well I mean we got
to do some shout outs to the baby got it
is a shout outs to the people who have
been subscribed yes well that is your
reward
i Trunks HD he said he loves my sex
jokes I was trying to make sex jokes
tonight and I fail I failed I mean I'm a
damn loser it's always happens Ronnie
got started you know cat is actually
she's really pretty isn't she
you guys it's it's like she's like
distractingly pretty this is her natural
hair color can you believe that [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's so hot
n-c-double-a Ron you know this guy said
said I'm like funny
did he say that you're so funny he said
I'm funny exhausting yeah I guess that's
like the highest coloman that's a pretty
good compliment some girls like funny
Michele Fernandez likes funny guys I
know she does woo it's like a like an
unofficial like shoutout right there no
I was looking at she gets a lot of
unsexual shot there [ __ ] yes that's
right
it's called building chemistry over the
Internet hey-oh there's also a death
killer 65 death killer 65 they have
their own channel there's good [ __ ] not
like you know [ __ ] usually smells bad
but they're kind of [ __ ] is really good
smelling you know it's like I would wear
this as cologne it looks like you pooped
out a complete meal or know if this is a
compliment anymore I just hate to get to
the point where like a shout-out offend
somebody no trust me I've made that
mistake many times okay